her fans now are showing up in uh
diapers or wearing adult diapers
to her concerts
and my mother's in a nursing home I'm
well I know what an adult diaper is I'm
well aware of an adult diaper
but they're wearing it in a non-fetish
way they're wearing it because they
would rather
themselves
then miss
a Taylor Swift song of which I couldn't
gun to my head could not tell you what
one of them is other than love story I
would have no idea gun in my mouth I go
I don't know
but apparently there's so many good ones
it never ends there's so it's hit after
hit after hit a breakup I'm back I love
him again I hate him I'm back I moved I
don't know what else is there in the
white woman world I was at a coffee shop
and I saw a guy